this one was disastrously done okay
let's have a look
you start with this absolute value graph
right that's f x and then you get asked
to graph this admittedly a little bit
weird having the absolute values over
there on this side we're not used to
that but it's still not that hard to
tackle if you just go about it in a
methodical way here's where i begin
absolute value of y equals f of x before
pen goes to paper on the graph
you already know right here there is a
restriction right here what is the
restriction that's implied by this line
good good good if this is an absolute
value right what's over here must be
positive right f x
must be greater than zero right
uh in other words if f of x is less than
zero there's nothing you can put into y
that satisfied that right so here's f of
x right this is y equals f of x
and there are some parts of this curve
where f x is not positive namely these
guys in here right
so i can't take anything from there and
put it into this
there's nothing that's going to satisfy
that right so immediately i just forget
about this part
okay i can ignore it because no part of
that graph is going to translate to the
one i'm doing now okay so now i've got
i'm left with this okay
now to come back to this the easiest way
to think about it is well what is what
does absolute value mean
and when you were first introduced to
absolute value like last year before
that
you learn a few definitions right you
learn for instance oh you just take the
positive value
that's one definition okay um another
definition is you take the distance
that's another definition um the most
technical definition which turns out to
be the most helpful in this context is
that
if i've got this right i'll write it
around the other way to make it a bit
clearer
f x equals the absolute value of y right
what this means is that f of x is equal
to two different things at two different
times okay it's equal to y sometimes and
other times it's equal to negative y
okay now you tell me obviously it's not
domain it's range in what range what
values of y
is this case true
when y is what
it's when y is
positive or equal to zero zero actually
kind of doesn't matter because it's
going to be the same outcomes so i i
tend to put the equality there even
though it's not a big deal okay
so it's equal to y when y is greater
than or equal to zero it's equal to
negative y everywhere else namely when y
is negative
okay so now you take this okay i'm
running out of space
i'll put it in here
you've got these two different uh
branches if you like okay
so you've got uh in some times f of x
equals y
that's when
y is greater than or equal to zero okay
so there's one case and then the other
case is
when y is less than zero
you've got this
now this is still a little bit weird but
i only have to do one more thing to make
sense of it okay let's come up to here
let's write this around the normal way
that we're used to okay so y is positive
it's just equal to the original graph
which is what i have here this was the
original graph i just dropped some bits
off of it okay
here i'll just make quite the subject
that's all i need to do y equals
negative f of x
so when y is less than 0 in other words
down here in the graph what's it going
to look like and the answer is it's
going to look like that
right so that's easy enough all you have
to do is flip it reflect it across the
x-axis so you get this
this branch all these branches down here
these are negative
f x and that's it that's all you have to
do okay
so admittedly even though the graph
looks so simple okay um there were lots
of people who had you know stuff in here
right because you missed you missed the
restriction um other people who had like
they just had the top half because they
thought oh you know it's gonna they
apply the absolute value to the right
hand side rather than the left hand side
okay so it's a very very simple graph
testing if you understand these concepts